hammam ammonia and his colleague I've
been on the lookout for giraffes for
almost two hours shy by nature the
majestic animals quickly does for cover
but eventually they emerge again Hamas
been working as a tour guide for an NGO
for several years giraffes are is
livelihood some I'm very pleased why'd
you working with your ass allows me to
feed my family you got Animal Farm you
growl as you love giraffes in West
Africa are threatened species twenty
years ago they were only 50 left here in
DJ the locals hunted them and their
habitats shrunk another problem was
drought which made force curse nadja
reform on gog scott rant kilo de
partager they consume up to 30 kilograms
of leaves per day akashiya they love
occasion ease and melons they are always
wandering through people's fields eating
the mangoes in their gardens le the
leisure o Siller ataka le manga fed up
with the jurors feasting on their
harvests locals intensified their
hunting giraffe meat was a welcome
change from a diet composed mainly of
millet corn and vegetables life here is
difficult the village leader describes
how climate change as affected people's
lives unlike idea but my aunt there is
less and less raining another call
everything else dried out that's made
life harder for us in the village of us
a smaller single chronicity almost sides
o kaanha culero a Sookie
this quartz those hardships the giraffes
are actually proven an unexpected boon
for the villagers they are now on the
protection enabling locals to benefit
financially from their preservation then
you did you are still from beans from
our gardens for instance there's little
we can do about it but we still like
them and don't hunt them any more of
them because they are now providing a
new source of income at cannot call it
dancing measures environment ministry
and the NGO even pay the villagers not
to hunt the giraffes authorities have
also established a protected area the
ten actor reserve features trees and
shrubs which provide the jurors with a
source of food as well as a breeding
ground misogyny allure at several or we
are here to help people of course this
is their land we want to improve it the
giraffes are an important part of its
version of when we protect the habitat
on course food sources and preserve data
which is beneficial to the villages
livestock des animaux domestica Kucera
on carbon FECA the twosome planting
grasses and shrubs helps slow down the
destruction of the landscape it's
decreases solar ocean and improves the
souls ability to absorb rainwater that
allows the giraffes to enjoy more melons
their favorite treat aven created the
protected area 16 years ago and it's
paid off the giraffe population has
rebounded to around 500 this in turn has
attracted more tourists the NGO now
employs a teen tour guides to meet the
demands of increasing tourism hammam
omunye describes how the measures have
improved people's lives same animal
Trezza important a bar salma anugerah
giraffes are important animals not only
in DJ but all around the world very
important by Roberto beaucoup pour la
populi Co they have helps to improve
villages quality of life sonra te pido
more places and now being supplied with
water as well as other commodities
school
facilities have been improved and nurses
have access to better equipment it has
certainly helped us a great deal alica
this is all down to the giraffes
comprame pora les fue de la zona dunks
are up book another result of the
program is that fewer people have been
moving to other parts of the country
instead they are staying put happy to be
able to make a living off the land once
hunted nearly to extinction the giraffes
have now become a welcome addition to
the landscape